se les pidió a eduardo ya paloma que
factorizar an la expresión 16 x cuadrada
menos 64 sus respuestas se muestran
abajo y aquí tenemos la respuesta de
eduardo que es 16 por x + 2 por x menos
2 y la respuesta de paloma fue 4x + 8
por 4x menos 8 nos preguntan cuál de los
estudiantes escribió una expresión
equivalente a 16 x cuadrada menos 64 muy
bien y como siempre te invito a que
hagas una pausa y trates de reflexionar
cómo podríamos factorizar esta expresión
para obtener por ejemplo la respuesta de
eduardo o la respuesta de paloma muy
bien primero vamos a tratar de
factorizar para ver si podemos obtener
el resultado de eduardo que es
justamente el que tenemos del lado
izquierdo verdad entonces como podemos
ver eduardo al parecer factor hizo un 16
verdad un número 16 de esta expresión
vamos a ver qué pasaría si nosotros
factorizar 16
bueno si factorizar los 16 tenemos 16
que multiplica a x cuadrada cierto y
luego restamos 16 y nos preguntamos qué
número hay que multiplicar a 16 para
obtener 64 y por supuesto la respuesta a
eso es 4 verdad 4 por 16 serían 64 y de
aquí podemos ver claramente que podemos
factorizar el número 16 verdad entonces
factor izamos el 16 y esto lo
multiplicamos por equis cuadrada menos 4
verdad que sería esta expresión de aquí
y esta otra expresión de acá muy bien
entonces nosotros ahora podemos utilizar
lo que ya sabemos sobre la diferencia de
cuadrados verdad esta es una diferencia
de cuadrados esto que tenemos aquí es
una diferencia de cuadrados y si quizás
esto te suena un poco raro bueno
podríamos ver los vídeos introductorios
en khan academy sobre la factorización
de diferencia de cuadrados pero
esencialmente lo que tenemos es algo de
la forma
v cuadrada y eso lo podemos factorizar
como a más b por a menos ve muy bien
entonces lo que tenemos en este caso
será 16 que multiplica que multiplica a
x2 verdad sería la digamos aquí en este
caso sería x y b sería 2 verdad entonces
tendremos x + 2 x x menos 2 entonces
esta expresión de aquí que teníamos como
una diferencia de cuadrados se
factorizar como el producto de estos dos
binomios y es justamente la respuesta
que obtuvo eduardo así que podemos
concluir que eduardo tiene una respuesta
correcta ahora veamos qué ocurre con el
caso de paloma y aquí podemos ver que ya
está factor izado verdad entonces parece
ser que paloma tuvo la habilidad de ver
rápidamente que esto ya era una
diferencia de cuadrados verdad así que
vamos a hacerlo con cuidado teníamos 16
x cuadrada
64 será nuestra expresión original y
esto podemos ver que es 4x todo elevado
al cuadrado verdad 4 al cuadrado es 16 x
al cuadrado es x cuadrada y luego
restamos 8 al cuadrado verdad 8 al
cuadrado de 64 así que aquí ya tenemos
nuevamente una diferencia de cuadrados
que podemos factorizar como 4x - bueno
primero con más 4x más 8 x 4x menos 8 y
si comparamos con la respuesta de paloma
podemos ver que esta respuesta también
es correcta